the Joe Rogan experience now when we
talk about technology and you talked
about the exponential increase in the
powers of technology is it possible that
we could come to a point in time
somewhere in the future where there's no
way to encrypt anything where it's not
possible to hide things where we won't
be able to do banking online we won't be
able to have digital currency because
virtually everyone will have access to
all the information because essentially
digital currency or anything it's
encrypted it's just information right
it's just ones and zeros is it possible
that technology will reach a point in
time where borders and boundaries are
impossible so I one thing that a lot of
people don't appreciate about
cryptography is there's a really
straightforward way to make completely
unbreakable cryptography and that's
what's called a one-time pad where if
you essentially have I'm you know a long
you know a very long set of data and
it's private as long as nobody else has
it you can encrypt anything with it and
if it was generated randomly properly
you always have to worry about flaws in
your random number generation or your
random number source but a properly
generated one-time pad is unbreakable
now the problem is it's finite so you
have a fixed amount of it and all of the
really serious spycraft would use
something like that where you've got a
one-time pad you can send a message
through it in the old days when you were
manually doing it you might only have a
book with a certain number of pages and
once it's over it's gone and you can't
get more without returning to base but
this is always a possibility and as
we've seen storage densities increase so
much the fact that you can get a little
micro SIM card that's holding hundreds
of gigabytes now which is pretty
remarkable
you could imagine a world like if we did
have this quantum apocalypse where all
of these short and 512 1024 bit Keys
whatever all of those just gets smashed
irrevocably I could imagine a world
where I mean heck maybe people start
implanting the one time pad inside
people so whatever you know whatever you
need to encrypt that's coming from you
has this you know this clear unbreakable
key that you're working with do you
think that we're going to have things
implants
our bodies soon that allow you to
interface with computers or technology
or wireless internet I think that it's
possible that it will I it would we have
people that want to do that right now in
fact that wasn't she implanted a Tesla
chip in her arm
so that she could just get close to her
car on the door would open so in fact
one of the things that talking with the
neural link people the idea that of
course right now you start off you say
you take somebody profoundly disabled
and you put them in a laboratory and you
try to train them how to use this but we
were all saying that what you really
need is a programmer to get this
interface you need to be able to let a
programmer actually program themselves
on their interface and you will make a
hundred times more progress than this
you know previously disabled person
coming into the lab for a couple hours a
day and it was funny the conversation
there where one of their guys is like
yeah we'll give him the basic rule so
they don't stroke themselves out and
like okay yeah that's kind of important
talk about health and safety rules there
but I yeah if you start getting a
programmer in there that starts running
this like alright instead of just going
through these basic exercises they run
everybody through you really understand
exactly what you're doing and you change
it you write the code as you're
experiencing it and there are probably
people volunteering that are ready to go
do that to have something like that I
read an article sometime after that
about one of the early neurosurgeons
that did implant himself with some
electrodes he had to go to one of these
I fringe countries that didn't have any
my ethical guidelines around the medical
practices or what everybody paid a
neurosurgeon in one of those countries
to implant an electrode into his head
and even had some complications
afterwards I was like now there's a
dedicated researcher although
interestingly there there's a whole
history of a lot of medical science
where you would get people that would
wind up having the conviction to do the
experiments on themselves and you know
you've got a respect that where it's one
thing to you know make a grant proposal
to set up a study to do all of this and
it's another one to say damn it I am so
confident in this I'm gonna have someone
cut a hole in my skull and implant this
in me so we can learn the lessons
what was his complications to your
murder he had some I have some problems
with speech afterwards he had to learn
how to do it like half of his face had a
little bit of a sag to it from the get
in there on so yes it was life
affecting changes as a result of going
with that and this was him
I don't offhand I but it what this was
it was a wired article I think from a
number of years back but this was like a
single electrode and it was just doing
very one bit or one analog value
computation and he had a little
transponder kind of put in under the
skin of his skull had a big lump on his
head with that while interesting again
the end the neural link stuff all modern
high tech where you kind of power it
with RF through the skull and it's got a
little plug and I one of the first when
you on first kind of approached me about
I kind of talking with them about that
the idea and the thinking which was kind
of insightful was this idea that the i/o
levels that they were doing on the
neural link or they were planning on
doing with that was fairly close to what
we do on virtual reality where okay
we've got theoretically maybe up to a
million inputs here and a million
outputs and I can run those numbers and
say well that's kind of like the cameras
that we're taking in in the display that
we're we're putting out and I made the
point that well you probably could run
that off of like Qualcomm chip that
we've got in here you'd set it all up as
like turn them into what are called mipi
lanes for the input and output make the
inputs look like a camera and make the
outputs look like a display screen and
you could then run software on something
like what we use here to drive your
brain like the programmer could then
kind of start running some of those
experiments with it
[Applause]